October is pretty quiet here at the
Capitol most members of Congress are at
home campaigning for re-election but
across town
October is way louder
this weekend brought postseason home
games to DC and Baltimore which got some
politicians talking it would be a great
world series to have Baltimore playing
nationally two-thirds of senators
represent states without Major League
Baseball the join my colleagues in the
yard later congratulating and watching
net so Harry Reid Mitch McConnell
they're free to root for the Nationals
in a town that's riveted by partisanship
and polarization I mean you know you you
aren't marked an R or a D or a liberal
or conservative if you're a Nats band
even Nancy Pelosi listen when she's
asked about the Giants whose home field
is in her district diamond I bet the
Giants and her that the audience I have
so many friends of mine who were
Nationals fanatics that I have to be for
the nation's you routinely see members
of Congress almost every game pretty
familiar to see a politician or a
lobbyists or a commentator wandering
around this stadium and I was here when
George Bush threw out the first pitch
for the new stadium I've seen Obama
stand up in the box when the White Sox
came to town Ben Bernanke the former
chairman the Fed used to come to almost
all the games chief justice has been to
games I see George will hear about every
third game Charles Krauthammer you kind
of find out who the baseball fans are I
tried to look but spotting a politician
at a sold-out playoff game is harder
than finding a Giants fan in this sea of
red
the gnats dropped two games to the
Giants but Washington fans are holding
out hope for a long-awaited championship
and the last time Washington won the
World Series with Calvin Coolidge was
president this week the Library of
Congress unearthed this film of the
Washington Senators defeating the Giants
the old ones from New York so this is
what a DC World Championship would look
like it's kinda nice to see that even if
you're wearing a suit at a baseball game
you jump the fence and rush a home play
that they win is that what will happen I
think the security is better now you
know chocolate is good for your teeth
it's my cup of coffee
you